hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of Rick and Morty's season 3 episode 9
the ABCs of beth the first episode in
three seasons to be named after and
focus primarily on Beth leaving us even
more confused about the show's reality
how many Beth clones Rick bodies Android
Morty's and misplaced Jerry's are we
dealing with here I made a separate
video covering all my theories on that
but here I'm gonna go into all the jokes
Easter eggs and deeper meaning that
you've might've missed yeah I know we
say every joke you missed and maybe you
didn't miss any or maybe you caught ones
we didn't but shut up let's just Rhian
joy this episode together and before I
start you know the drill we want to
thank our friends from kwid for
sponsoring this video
Quade is an app that allows you to drag
and drop stickers on the text message
threads including Rick and Morty themed
ones for more details later okay let's
get started with the title of this
episode the ABCs of Beth is a reference
to the 2012 limited release film the
ABCs of death kind of like last episodes
Morty's mine blowers the ABCs of death
is a horror comedy anthology made up of
26 shorts all death themed it's an
interesting movie not all the shorts are
great and I think the ABCs of Beth has a
deeper meaning than this jokey reference
which I'll get to at the end but for now
let's cover all the other pop culture
influences this episode in our segment
under the influence okay first this
chalk that Rick uses to draw open the
door to fruit peel and well it's
probably influenced by Pan's Labyrinth
in that movie a girl kind of like Beth
uses chalk to open a portal to a fairy
tale world that's actually super
horrifying this visual also reminded me
a lot of the show chalk zone also notice
how Rick describes how he created it
that collapsed a quantum tesseract a
quantum tesseract could be a reference
to the tesseract sequence in the movie
interstellar and that movie a scientist
father also uses a quantum tesseract to
help his adult daughter cope with her
abandonment issues and eventually leave
her world behind now the character
Chiara the crew tab Yulin warrior seems
to be influenced by a few different
sci-fi sources first she's kind of a
combination of the xenomorph from alien
with the elongated head but also the you
to Jay warrior from the predator movies
meanwhile the varix that they hunt they
actually look a bit more like the
Predators and the way their mouths open
but then again they turn into these
xenomorph crawling facehuggers whenever
they get decapitated so it seems like
they're kind of sharing qualities anyway
I guess it kind of makes this that these
two would be enemies that is if you
consider
the alien versus Predator movies to be
sensical also her blue skin and soul
bond Monica mystic mating behavior is a
lot like the Navi of Avatar and yeah
she's got three boobs first thing I
noticed too I just wanted to cover
everything else first
that is obviously reference to the three
boobs sex worker in total recall later
notice this line from Rick life finds a
way is a reference to Goldblum's
character in Jurassic Park life actually
one could argue dr. Ian Malcolm's chaos
theory is a very influential source for
Rick's nihilistic worldview feel free to
use that in your next media studies term
paper nerds and this might have just
been me but I was getting some major
Game of Thrones vibes from Tommy's fruit
peel and Kingdom with Rick and durian an
endless list of royal titles and then
refusing an eel kind of like how Jon
Snow did this past season you stand in
the presence of Daenerys Stormborn of
House Targaryen rightful heir to the
Iron Throne rightful queen of the Andals
and the first men so I assume my lord
you're here to bend the knee I am NOT
and then King Tommy also says this I
always find the theater is the best way
to clarify things live theater is also
something we saw in Game of Thrones in
season 6 the mummer's forest depicted
the bastardize history of that show
killing the man will do you no good
really we got a credit Shakespeare with
this Shakespeare data at Hamlet uses the
play within a play device to guilt his
uncle Claudius and to confessing his
crime just like this kids play brings
the truth out of Beth well kind of well
that's interesting news yeah this is the
second time this season the show alluded
to the fake news of the 2016 US
presidential election this whole concept
of children born of incest re-enacting
bestiality and cannibalism is easily
this episodes darkest moment especially
when you consider that they got real
children to record these lines so you
may survive and as dark as that is if
you think about it all these details are
totally influenced by the Bible Adam and
Eve as an origin story doesn't work
without incest guys also eating my flesh
that you may survive is a total Jesus
line
maybe I'm just still traumatized from
Darren Aronofsky's mother the extended
list joke of Rick rattling off the
creepy toys Beth had to make for her is
my favorite part of this episode I love
how later Beth uses the indestructible
bat the ladybug taser and the pink
sentient switchblade this whip that
forces people to like you maybe a nod to
Wonder Woman's lasso of truth I guess a
whip that forces people to like you is
kind of the opposite of that as I like
that we get a nod to Disney's The Parent
Trap but with a literal bear trap later
summer says this to Morty
Isak [ __ ] is a reference to Isaac
Asimov the science fiction author behind
iRobot and nightfall who's a major
influence on the sci-fi of Rick and
Morty and of course there was this line
from Rick zero chance of going Blade
Runner this of course is a reference to
the replicants of the movie Blade Runner
Bai beings that pose as humans and
secretly try to replace us there's
actually a deeper thematic connection to
Blade Runner in this episode and I go
into that in my other video now this
ending with Morty and some are returning
to possibly clone Beth also reminded me
a lot of that scene in Rick Nancy in the
stone which featured kind of a mirror
opposite version of the scene with real
Beth joining the artificial versions of
her kids at the table let's actually go
through all the other series continuity
references in this episode in our
segment callbacks early in this episode
rick digs the fruit peel and chalk out
of this yuto box now Yuto rember is the
u-haul brand of truck from the pilot and
earlier this season and if you look
closely inside that yuto box you can see
Rick's meeseeks box and The Vindicator
beacon later in the background of the
sushi restaurant
Brad sits at one of the tables remember
Brad as Jessica's ex-boyfriend from Rick
potion number nine and Rick see business
also Rick drinks from the same canned
beverage that we saw him drinking last
episode and one of memories foo knees
and this wasn't too hard to catch but
when Beth looks at the family photos on
the fridge among them are the old family
dog snuffles
and longtime definitely real mister
poopy butthole right moving on I really
love the wordplay in this episode
especially when Rick foreshadows how
incest is a big thing in fruit peel and
you're supposed to put elbow grease into
your daughter groceries there are
actually a lot of subtle sexual
innuendos this episode which gives me an
excuse to bring back my favorite Rick
and Morty breakdown segment
Hidden Dickies okay there is this
exchange with Chiara I know where
crew-cab ulam's are from dead a chime in
Touhou chime Antonio younglings Hyman
Cho though it's actually fitting for
summer to make a Freudian slip like this
the last time she met sexy alien women
they were the COS or pians pretty much
everything in their society was based on
female anatomy
speaking of which Jerry then says this
not so subtle line I'm sure you noticed
what she has three of but guess what she
has two of now there are two things that
I love about this one I love how the
editing leaves this long pause after the
line which just plays up Morty in
summers duh reaction there this also
sets up a really fun subtle joke later
but before I get to it quick aside here
to keep the lights on this video was
sponsored by quid big thanks to them
wait is an app where you can collect
cool stickers cards and punk Oh figures
for free on your phone if you use emojis
and stickers when you text your friends
quit as thousands of free stickers that
you can't find anywhere else from shows
like the just-released Game of Thrones
Rick and Morty Steven universe Bob's
Burgers Powerpuff Girls and Family Guy
cult hits like Breaking Bad and Star
Trek and from games like five nights at
Freddy's and fallout you could just drag
and drop these stickers and iMessage
see I love rekha Morty be my friend now
if you collect Funko pop figures quit as
those two some of these stickers cards
and toys are super rare and hard to get
some good luck but the good news is you
can meet cool people on quit look at
their collections and trade with them
just as easily as quickly as chatting
with each other there's also a new
feature you can showcase your collection
by adding stickers to images you already
have on your camera roll just check out
the profile tab on iOS new stickers
cards and figures that you can collect
for free are released every day
including a surprise big new show coming
soon okay second thing I love about this
crew tabula an Anatomy joke notice how
later Kyra's ex-boyfriend Tran door has
three pecs and that's really what would
he have to of notice the two hanging
pieces of loincloth they're also I love
the animation design of the fru-u--
pians notice how they all have patches
of Tommy's blonde hair this one another
hidden dickey fleshy testicles hanging
off his chin later when Rick goes
through the box of Beth's creepy toys
two of the first ones are a whip and
handcuffs yeah both of which could be
used as SNM bondage type sex toys kind
of makes them a bit disgusting that Rick
made these for his daughter and this
episode features another disgusting song
the doo doo in my butt song that Rick
was hard even composed earlier
from a father's blood biologically
speaking the but is it not biologically
speaking a but isn't a nut but it does
actually work kind of with a mutant
biology logic of fruit peel and we're
pregnant creatures apparently poop their
offspring at mature and as much as I
love the dick jokes let's move on to a
more clever wordplay a joke it's nothing
matters why would you do that for me I
don't know maybe you matter so little
that I like you maybe it makes you
matter
maybe I love you maybe something about
your mother don't jump a gift shark in
the mouth now don't jump a gift shark in
the mouth is a mix of the phrases don't
look a gift horse in the mouth
I don't question the intentions of the
gifts people give you and jump the shark
which is a common phrase for when a TV
show goes too over-the-top breaking the
reality of its original concede and
turning off viewers let's actually go
deeper into how this episode breaks the
fourth wall with a new segment I'm
Colleen so medical by the way real quick
jump the shark is a reference to a
classic episode of happy days when
Fonzie literally jumped over a shark on
water skis in this case Justin roiland
are Dan Harmon are hinting that by
ambiguously implying Beth could be a
clone they're officially jumping the
shark now I would argue Rick and Morty
jumped the shark in a pilot episode and
is all the better for it but that's just
me now earlier in the episode Rick says
this after the kids play okay
yeah certified fresh this is a joke
about rotten tomatoes the movie and TV
review aggregator site which labels
things certified fresh' win enough
critics like it friggin Morty season
three by the way is certified fresh'
later rick says this here's some things
an adventure needs Beth conflicts takes
away from me to benefit and clearly
Morty hmm so man these sound like Roland
and Harmons requirements for every
episode of Rick and Morty conflicts
takes some way that Rick can benefit and
yeah even if he isn't part of the main
narrative Morty still has to be part of
the story somehow later Morty says this
to Jerry
you taking it Morty is referencing the
term Davis ex machina a Greek term
meaning late in the story move where
characters miraculously gets safe
without really earning it rigor mortis
definitely made deus ex machina an art
form there was also this final joke of
the episode Arno
those isn't closed in the dimension
where they didn't invent daylight
savings by the way that wasn't time
travel they were just a couple pizzas on
the counter I grabbed him
so here Rick is explaining the time
logic of this even if the other
dimension didn't have daylight savings
Rick wouldn't have been able to order a
pizza and wait for it to cook in a
matter of second so basically he's
saying nerds don't ever think this but
this is also a medic comment about the
show Rick and Morty has never done a
time travel episode Marilla and harmon
have made this a rule even though the
characters are based loosely on doc and
Marty from Back to the Future the
writers feel like time travel has been
beaten to death in all scifi stories so
instead they can see the ultimate
realities as a way to explore the
universe finally there's this great meta
joke about the answering machine
yeah answering machines do signature
lines it comes
okay let's blows out by talking about
the deeper meaning of this episode ok so
again this episode was called the ABCs
of Beth which could refer to a few
things the movie ABCs of death but it
also sounds like the title will that
play that the kids perform the ABCs of
how Beth is this evil devil figures also
notice how this acronym ABC shows up in
this key moment with Rick my advice take
off put a saddle on your universe let it
kick itself out I can't do that the kids
Jerry my job and as much as I hate to
admit it ABC's The Bachelor show the
ABCs the Beth are in this episode the
life that Beth currently lives where she
feels evil so what makes a person in
this world evil that question comes up
in both storylines this episode notice
what Jerry tells us kids and later he
confesses this to Kiara
I'm not an evil person I'm lazy I'm
cowardly and and I do not know what I'm
doing meanwhile Rick is this classic
take on the concept of evil to his
daughter am i evil worse you're smart
when you know nothing matters the
universe is yours for Rick being evil is
just a less extreme version of the true
nihilism an extremely intelligent person
feels toward the world this episode Beth
returned to a smaller version that world
the fantasy fruit peel and and she tries
to fix it but ultimately she just just
and starts over this world that Rick
built for her is just a smaller scaled
dollhouse of the broader universe that
he lives in Jerri admits that he's too
stupid and inept to be evil he's the
grazing animal that Rick alluded to
meanwhile Beth is like her father beyond
these simplistic categorizations of good
and evil
Beth is too capable and intelligent to
let her world container do you think
Beth at the end of the episode is a
clone or do you think she stayed having
a last minute change of heart that we
didn't see also do you think Beth has
the potential to be more destructive
than Rick is comment down below and
let's keep this debate going all week
until the season finale on Sunday the
Richter Ian Moir to date Dan this season
went by too fast also we're gonna do
another giveaway
Rick and Morty Funko pop figures - thank
you guys for watching and sticking
around to the end just follow new
rockstars on Twitter and share a link to
this video with the hashtag new Rick
stars and we'll send a few of you these
vinyl figures can also hit me up on
twitter at EA vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for all of our Rick and Morty
deep dives hey if you want to support
this channel so that maybe one day we
can eventually avoid having hannover up
videos with ads you can contribute to
new rock stars on patreon see you next
week bye